bah cassany vous avez le bac oui bien
pourquoi bien sûr j'ai même mention
assez bien même mention ac 2 0
il le donnait à l'époque vous ludivine
vous avez pas quad
ouais mais à larache alors qu'elle a
l'âge il est rêveur peu comme j -louis
un bac littéraire mais moi le prof
il m'a donné 0,5 au bac parce qu'il
voulait pas avoir à remplir de paperasse
tellement j'étais nul à chier vraiment
si vous avez compris cette anecdote des
gérontes bellemare au jeu mais s'ils
prouvent ou deux fois est ce que toi tu
expliques non ouais
et s'il est vrai que c'est vrai donc
l'étagé pas toujours été flic avec a été
inventé j'avais fait des études de
diététique
non messieurs ouais j'ai pris mais je me
suis pris à deux fois pour le bac la
première fois j'ai eu trois milles
moyenne sur non massif et staff et était
en fait j'avais jeté à l'eau je veux
aller aux compétitions
là ça devait pas venir à la base mais
pas venir c'est toujours comme ça c'est
toujours ceux qui sont passés venir qui
s'éclate le plus est le prof enfin je
relise mais mes profs me disait il faut
choisir entre le vélo et les études je
suis cette année ce sera le vélo donc
j'étais au bout au fond de la salle et
puis ma prof d'allemand s'arracher les
cheveux parce que je faisais l'arrogant
quoi oui mais toi tu fais l'arrogant
faye a favorisé dirait jolie brise et
des plus coriaces que de justesse bats
toi tu te laisses tenu de justesse les
meufs que ta patrie et les a pas du tout
la veille les appareils ios qui va le
sauver sont les activités artistiques
que les options de théâtre 1920 j'avais
un jeu excentrique et ça a plu ou ouais
vous avez vous ai présenté quoi au
théâtre c'est pas connu c'était d'une
thèse contemporaine ça faisait [ __ ] de
solex genève y élire leur maire
c'est un sourd dans le
c'est ça le jury j'avais travaillé dans
sur la simplicité et bien sûr en
contrepartie ils m'ont demandé de le
faire mais hier x 36 et donc j'ai un
truc extra alors oui vous savez le
brevet d'état 2 d'études et c'est dans
cette école
moi j'ai une bac annonçant très bien
jure sur la vidéo ben oui mais j'ai pas
le choix parce que j'avais deux ans de
retard en 5e jeter cancre jusque là donc
après n'est pas mais elle est en
cinquième avec 10 à 25 la caisse est la
seule à la fin des quotas
monsieur je vous ramène choqués tant pis
ça devait ramener les profs à l'école
celle qui conduisait le bus alors oui
quand vous étiez away est mon seul point
faible à l'époque je vous dis j'avais
pas le choix et 16 en philo au bac et
mon seul point c'est vrai à l'époque
c'était la gymnastique je suis dit il
faut que je me fasse dispensé de
gymnastique way
sinon je sais même pas faire une roulade
avant comment je vais faire et alors
donc j'écris je suis qu'une toute petite
créature qu'elle et brad ou tort de ne
rien faire
on m'a dit prouvez le donc j'ai tendu
mémoire est comme ça voilà il m'a dit
aulas et les jambes c'est pareil ce qui
est pas vrai mais j'ai dû à oui c'est
peut-être un cauchemar il va dire la
peau il s'est tourné vers elle un tel
handicap nord il faut la dispenser j'ai
mal joué voilà un rendez vous
anglaise emmanuel la demande et donc
attendez le prof
vous êtes arrivé comme ça il a laissé
comme la guerre et bombardements le
maire devant ouvrir ici la très bonne
battre paco bonsoir commencent à avancer
les bassa alors oui c'est mon chéri paco
voilà qui fait partie des
téléspectateurs qui reviennent nous voir
aussi et vous venez vous nous envoyez
des candidatures vous dès qu'on voulait
savons pas quoi tu fais quoi déjà dans
la vie joue un restaurant au mois de
mars a ouais c'est vrai bon cigare four
comme elle va s'appeler je n'ai pas le
bac je me dis tout va s'appeler casa
pelletier casa pelletier vous allez
faire des biscottes
pour ce qui est des courses moi j'ai la
chance d'aller très souvent ils
supermarché ailleurs faire les courses
oui quoique bien ça vous fait chier
mercy corps rokhaya diallo merci d'être
là merci
mention bien moi j'étais la première de
la classe avec les grosses lunettes tout
maigre 1 c'était moi non c'est vrai
avoue ouais mais voilà maigret cheval à
grosses lunettes et j'ai toujours était
première de la classe elle est aussi
j'avais des lunettes mais en plus quand
j'étais petit un cache sur un défi mais
non mais on dirait la meuf ont bien
accueilli quand mais il y en a plein
vous imaginez tous les ans c'est parce
que monde avec des lunettes rouges et
d'un spectacle avec ses bras tordu
merci donc ça qu'on chope des fois oui
oui vous avez qu'elle vous avez votre
premier amoureux et ben ça va vous
surprendre
oui c'est toujours eu des petits
amoureux et c'était le camp le premier
set et quand je vais voir si sept ans
n'ont pas de l'amour non salut l'artiste
[Rires]
d'emblée aimions edmond j il s'appelait
phéniciens jj l'usiné non ah bah ouais
merde
ah merde ah ouais là il a pris dans la
gueule quoi c'est vrai et après c'était
fini 2e dan et c'est vrai que tu as fait
le jury pour les gars à quito je n'ai
pas légal de la base ils sont les gars
qu'on tenait la route
ça fait six ans que la côté ouest tu
connais et le deuxième simple et comment
patrick non ouais le 3e christian non
mais quatrième lionel tullow oil et vous
vous avez fait des bonds à mon avis je
vais pas faire que les choses se soient
interdites émission ce soir je suis pas
bon soir vous êtes jean-michel s'était
pas vous merci les attentions à mâcher
elle habite à montpellier elle a trois
soeurs frères elle habite chez ses
parents ce une très longue sportive
niveau national à natation championne de
france en minimes cadets juniors en
brasse bref si c'est vrai ouais bah quoi
sur i way de justesse n'y avait pas en
fait j'étais parti pour pas l'avoir away
donc toi que je mélange des deux mesures
et toi grâce au sport va être affecté
une grande partie c'était magnifique et
on va lire mon test est paraplégique
suite à un accident de la route il ya
trois ans avec ta soeur et tu continues
le sport
oui pas fou je me suis mis à bas je me
suis mis à l'athlétisme et j'ai continué
la natation mais j'ai fait les
championnats de france n2 mais je me
suis mis à l'athlétisme pour découvrir
autre chose alors que nous on a un
projet tu connais stéphane houdet le
champion de tennis - en demi finale de
l'open d'australie
voilà un gros projet on va essayer de
faire mettre des valides aussi au tennis
au handi tennis or tu auras c'est hyper
dur à faire vraiment un championnat
parce que j'ai tenté je peux vous dire
qu'il faut être très très fort c'est
exceptionnel mais j'en ai fait un peu de
tennis et c'est dire demain 8h tracasse
fracasse tiens ton animatrice préférée
c'est daphné burki j'aime bien ton
animateurs préférés c'est qu'ils
n'aillent sétois et et et sans moi
j'aime bien dechavanne d'accord très
bien et les missions que tu adores cela
dit je t'aime touche pas à mon poste et
salut les terriens way sa démission tu
détestes suis pas non mais j'aime pas
trop entre eux tout est permis
jamais trop et quand c'est le samedi son
préféré c'est et j'aimerais bien
bruno mars c'est là qu'elle pleure quand
tu mets du versace sur la violence
envers cet homme de flores ont la
perception de fleurs et sans crainte
qu'après on est dans la
[Musique]
baboo comment je vis dans le groupe à
oui c'est comme quand tu as passé les
trente ans et que tu es tu as une meuf
qui te demande ton al fait toujours
comme ça une meuf voit deux ans le 22
avril au 3 mai et attaquer lâche toi
j'ai quinze mois c'est gégé 29 battu moi
j'avais des tapas et mécontents value
nous avait pas et j'ai le choix je n'ai
pas eu et j'ai fait le minimum pour
l'avoir c'est tout mais ce n'est pas
toujours le minimum chicon je peux oui
wen va très bien merci mais la cbc je
vais quand même je peux dire un petit
mot je vais rendre un petit hommage
modeste mais vraiment sincère à jean-luc
je sais qu'il nous regarde c'est
tellement on va lui dire que on n'oublie
pas évidemment on n'oublie pas sur tout
ce qu'il a donné gestion d un truc tu
nous manques
non nous y va tous y adonner à
l'émission je sais que je serais pas là
où je suis aujourd'hui sans lui
mais voilà même j'ai appris de ses
erreurs aussi voilà maintenant j'essaie
de bien sûr et le flambeau avec mes
modestes talent je fais ce que je peux
et jean luc decaster besoin d aide on
est là alors moi j'ai pas eu le bac mais
j'ai des bonnes raisons en fait non
j'explique mais là bas ça m'a pris pour
le conseiller pour ses fans et j'imagine
très bonnes raisons en fait je débutais
un bac en alternance en bac pro d'accord
on indique way est en fait pour être
accepté dans l'entreprise
j'ai dû épines et l'anus de ma patronne
à vache quoi vrai oui je veux dire quoi
donc suis rentré chez moi le sport
national il a tant donné je vais faire
je dois refaire un teaser sur let
elle est apparemment séduit maille à
partir avec un anus
[Rires]